monsieur jean paul belmondo
qui est le légionnaire romain deux
deuxièmes places
jean paul belmondo demetrius adhère
détective privé non
horace mac tout près de cannes a dit non
jeff trotsky aventuriers nom
jeff miller avocat et oui maintenant que
vous êtes tous réunis
permettez moi de vous faire mes excuses
ben vous ne comprenez pas messieurs je
m'excuse d'une seule chose c'est de ne
pouvoir payer ma dette à tous trois en
effet monsieur à tous a le droit de me
tuer le premier ce qui ôte beaucoup de
valeur votre créance monsieur porthos et
rend la vôtre à peu près nulles monsieur
aramis je risque donc de faire
banqueroute à l'un de vous a deux
peut-être voilà de quoi je m'excusais
rien de cela